are we I fell asleep in a parking lot
I wanted to go to a bar to to have a
drink and I
I fell asleep before I even came inside
I slept for the first time in ages
I couldn't even call
I fell asleep like I said
where is Ruby she's upstairs in a crib
she's fine don't go up there and wake
her I guess she had a really nice night
together good
I'm happy for you yeah
well it was nice to get some time with
her finally okay well I shouldn't I
shouldn't have come back at all then
yeah okay that's not what I meant
I'm gonna work
somewhere around here has to
become man you like to spend time with
her on your terms but then you leave
whenever it becomes inconvenient all I
said was it was nice okay you're the one
who left on that I got tired okay I made
a mistake one time was it
a mistake
what do you mean I don't know you seem
pretty unhappy I love her
and you don't
hey do not walk away from me Spencer
talk to me great
great woke her up
it's okay Ruby I heard you just stop
[Music]
come on
sorry
I'm sorry
[Music]